welcome everyone and welcome to the
third day of parieta global and i hope
that last two days were amazing
uh so we are today joined by arena and i
would be speaking on the prototype hole
and tools to help your event
so arena over to you and could you
please start with a short bio for
yourself that would be wonderful
okay yeah actually um it's in it's very
soon in the in those slides um so just
first thank you all for for joining
today um in fact i'm going to what i'm
going to be presenting today is really a
continuation of of chats that have been
going on in pi data over the last couple
of days i've seen this come up in talks
already
and so it seems to be happening in well
it doesn't seem
i know that it's been happening in in
different places um the what triggered
this or the the excuse to talk about
this if you will
was um an article that came up um
talking about how
they called it ai tools they were
covering data science data-driven
machine learning tools
and and how they had translated to tools
that helped with covet or that well
didn't
um i've also seen another paper
that looked at other papers that had
been published over
well during the year
during a year of collecting data and
trying to come up with models for for
for diagnostics for prognosis um and how
what well actually what what the the
the authors found was that all of them
had
severe methodological flaws
and none of them really qualified to to
go up to to products
that could help in a clinical setting
um now i care about this um and this is
where i can tell you a bit about myself
um because well i've got a past in in
med tech and then i've spent several
years around computer vision machine
learning products and in startups and
now um in the mobility sector by the way
the opinions here on my own i'm not here
representing my employer so this is all
opinions about what i've seen in
different sectors over the years
what i'm assuming about you is that you
also care about this that you've been
involved in machine learning data driven
computer vision
all that domain um
prototypes potentially products and that
you would like to to increase that ratio
of product to to prototype that we have
now the first thing i i wanted to do was
ask okay if we have that situation which
in truth we do
why is that
um
and and to be fair by the way um there
are many applications that have helped
in covered that and help us every day so
we know that i don't know in logistics
there's plenty there there has been
plenty going on um
every so
there's there's a lot of of tools of
data-driven tools that have been helping
however um in the clinical setting not
so much so why was that
um and you'll see how this relates to
other sectors as well now the first
thing that they identified was was that
they were working
in less than ideal settings
um and i thought okay is this only in
academia
it's definitely unfair to say it's just
academia so
okay where do practitioners go when
they're first exploring maybe kaggle you
go to kaggle and then you suddenly see
that there's 3 800 data sets and bear in
mind this is data collected over a year
almost 4 000 data sets is bonkers
so there might be something in there too
but let's keep asking why
um so why why do we have the situation
and through math racial racial
performance from thomas from from
um i
reached the covey tracking project and
they have published several articles
covering their problems collecting data
um and and processing it and how they
they had a huge disconnect between the
people who were publishing that data the
metrics they were using what the data
they were publishing meant
which rendered any pipelines that they
could have set completely useless
now so again why do we have the
situation
well luckily
several articles have covered
recommendations to both practitioners in
the industry and in academia
about how to proceed
so then
what we the the factors that kept coming
up again and again were
that disconnect between domain experts
and what we'll call ai people and i'm
saying ai very loosely as usual covering
data science machine learning a bit of
data-driven tools basically
so there's this disconnect between the
domain and the data people they're not
talking to each other they're not using
the same terminology they don't know the
same things
there was also a problem about data
heterogeneity so basically ms
no standardization
there's also a problem in
reproducibility so there's again a
disconnect between and this time between
data people and other data people
because if somebody if others cannot
reproduce what you're doing they also
cannot jump in and help you
so
what can we do about this and how does
this and of course this relates to other
sectors this is not just academia it's
definitely not just in in clinical
science this is happening everywhere we
see it in any sector we've worked in
so what can we use to make it easier
now i'm going to approach this um
through the machine learning cycle so
you've seen variations of this in plenty
of places
and i would start and this obviously
starts with the with understanding
what's going on
and there are several other steps that
we that we all need to go through and
i'm going to emphasize the human factor
so again remember the problems that we
were seeing and i'm going to show them
again
where this disconnect between humans
in different steps of the problem
so which rendered domain node which
which meant that we were losing domain
knowledge and it made our data
useless and it made it even made our
code almost useless right so in each of
these steps where you're understanding
the business you need to be
communicating efficiently with humans
when you're sourcing your data when
you're labeling when you're versioning
so that others know what you're using
you need to be keeping in mind other
humans
we can let's assume model creation is a
bit of a silo shouldn't but is but okay
but in deployment you're also thinking
about how people are going to be
consuming the predictions that you make
so you need to be thinking about humans
last of all monitoring because no model
can stay the same forever it would
completely fail
and typically this makes you have to go
through the merry-go-round again
now let's keep in mind these three
problems right
especially the disconnect between domain
and data people and the problem in
reproducibility
so starting with the business
understanding what tools can we use to
make things more efficient there
and the first one i'm going to give you
isn't even coat it's the only one that
isn't code but but it's a really good
one
and this one i i found out about at a
meetup
where leader art was presenting the tool
and it's basically about asking the
right questions and being systematic
about it so before i knew about this
is his machine learning canvas i had a
checklist
where you typically have to go through
someone either from your employer your
customer your user you sit down with
them and you start asking things about
how they're what exactly is their
problem how do they want you to solve it
what data do they have how where is this
going to be running and what kind of ui
are they expecting where does this fit
in their decision process so a lot of
questions that really matter so that
you're not just in your corner doing fun
stuff but the output can really have an
impact in what people are doing in their
business
so the the good thing about either
choose having your checklist choose
this canvas choose whatever you want but
the importance is that you don't skip
steps that you make sure that you cover
all of these topics
now that doesn't stop there because
humans have a really hard time
describing what they want
usually they know when they see it but
not always but at least what you can do
is is
prepare a really quick prototype end to
end so a toy version of what it's going
to be end to end to at least let them
tell you if you're completely off the
mark and to avoid what you could call
the magical box syndrome like okay so i
yeah no i've got this problem let's ai
solve it okay but how specifically what
kind of predictions do you need what are
you going to put in and get out
and this is where i'm going to be
talking about um a couple of really nice
tools
um
so i
personally because i don't work that
much with dashboards i really like
radio which what it does this gives you
an a ui that you can stick on top of say
a jupiter notebook or any any any of
anything else really so if you've got
you've got your python code you need to
to prepare a quick
a quick user interface and you stick
this on top and it gives you a nice way
of communicating already with your user
if you on the other hand
use dashboards
i will i should point you to a workshop
that happened
two days ago so thursday
the dashboard showdown where tools like
the one i know best is is trimulate but
there's the classic there's other
classical ones like dash and others that
um that are being described here so i
would point you in that direction
but the point of all this is
get a user interface of some sort to
your user as early as possible so they
can tell you what they want
now let's talk about data and how that
still relates to the human factor
now the only way to extract domain
knowledge from your users from your
domain expert
and put it into your models is through
the data that's the whole point of
data-driven applications right so how do
they how can they give you that through
labeling
now when you sit with them that's when
you suddenly realize
that there are no labels and then comes
the sequel of that uh magic called black
box syndrome but there's this thing
called unsupervised you solve it with
unsupervised learning
that's a hard conversation
there's plenty of literature that can
compare results of unsupervised versus
supervised methods
but what you can do after you have that
conversation is sit down with them and
discuss about labeling
and you want to make it easy for them
so there's tools that can help you um
for instance if you're in it's going to
be very modality dependent right so if
you're working with images
uh one i really like is see that
it's for mental but it's open source
because you can already stick a
pre-trained method behind it let it do
predictions and and have your users
correct them but there's others that can
help them just sit down and go sample by
sample and annotate
now that's a bit too much so i really
like
another another approach like human
learn which is it kind of relates to to
see that but for text
where um and here shout out to to
vincent varmadam and
be sure to to check his his talk in in
pi date amsterdam
um where the whole idea is maybe you can
find clusters of data
represent them plot those
representations plot those embeddings
and have your user just kind of draw to
to tell you what they find in common in
them and that's a way of translating
what's in their head which is extremely
valuable because that's where the you
know the devil is in the details and not
all data is the same not all sectors are
the same
so that's a way of translating that
into your data so that you can make your
models better
and again i'm going to bring up gradio
and i swear i'm not i'm not affiliated
to them um
but
where if you need something else then
you're going to have to prepare an
annotation tool pretty quickly
um so that's where a tool like this can
come in
um and i particularly like it because um
there's this nifty flag button which
means that if you're showing say
predictions from a model that you've
already pre-trained
and they see something that doesn't ring
true they can just click on it and say
this was a bad prediction
and that state and that's an annotation
you can add very easily
last thing about this please version
your data and help your colleagues help
you
i'm not going to stop your model
creation um mostly because it's it takes
about 90 percent of the time we talk
about these things but really it's like
five percent of the total work
all i'm going to say is there's plenty
of tools to track your experiments
please find one that you like and use it
but let's now talk
about deployment
so assume that you already have your
model
and you need to start thinking again
about how your user is going to be
consuming the data and where
and that's where and hopefully you
thought about this already in the
initial step
but perhaps you forgot and then you need
to ask them um are you going to be using
this say in your phone
or are you going to be using it
somewhere else and if it's on a device
does it have it maybe they're sitting in
an office where there's no connectivity
or maybe they're in a workshop
or maybe they are somewhere where
there's simply no data connection maybe
because of privacy reasons
and then you realize that every that all
the processing because of how they work
their workflow you're going to be
constrained to deploy your models on a
device with no connectivity and it has
to be running on device
so after crying there are tools that you
can use
um typical ones are well tensorflow lite
and that's been there for now for years
if if you're going if you're targeting a
very specific um hardware like if you're
going to be
using arm devices or or intel devices
they all have their own specific
libraries so take a look
bear in mind that what you will be able
to deploy in mind especially if if
you're doing deep learning if you're
using neural networks
bear in mind that not all of the layers
that these libraries support are
are so bear in mind that not everything
that you can train with tensorflow with
pie church will be available to you in
these so they typically have a lag and
and they don't always implement
everything in those frameworks
and in any case always use a light model
now
if you're not constrained in that way if
you don't have to worry about
tiny ml and processing on a device
then there you have a ton of more of
more options
um there's tools like mlflow and benzoml
that can help you ship or package and
serve behind an api
many so models trained with many
different libraries i tend to prefer ml
flow because i'm i'm lazy so if i'm
already tracking my experiments with ml
flow then i can just package it and
serve it but there's other options
available to you and also i'm sure i've
seen
uh here the other day
in pi data global uh a talk about torch
serve
um and so i would encourage you to look
it up if you're interested in it
now if you prefer being a bit more
uh in control of what you're doing and
you want to to define it you can also
write your own your own api so there's
tools like fast api to help you do it a
bit better and of course flask has been
there really long
so if you prefer that go for it
one last comment if you don't really
know what what platform you're going to
be
it's strange that you don't know where
you're going to be deploying but if you
want to remain a bit generic
think of of exporting your models in the
onyx format
hopefully one day all
deep learning
frameworks support a standardized method
standardized packaging
and it could be onix so that we don't
have to worry about converting from one
to the other so this is the closest
we've come
last step of all
monitoring
so
you've you've managed to to train
something that you're happy with
you know that it does what your users
were expecting
you've actually deployed it um and then
well of course that's just the start of
the journey right because the moment you
deployed you realize
that your data has your real data in
production has nothing nothing to do
with what you had trained on
and so you need to retrain again and
again
and i'm really hoping for your own sake
that you had that automated otherwise
well get started and automate your
training pipelines
now
for that monitoring of metrics and you
typically want to be monitoring things
like sure things like latency
things like cup time
but here for machine learning models
you're going to want to to to be keeping
track of how it fares in incoming data
as opposed to all data so maybe you will
have to have a lag while you're
annotating production data because like
that's the whole point you didn't have
labels for it
and so there's going to be a lag but
make sure that you are tracking
performance
whatever your metric is
on the real data so when that
performance deviates from what you
expect
an alarm can be triggered so you you can
be storing it with uh with prometheus
you're keeping an eye on it on with
grafana and there's libraries that you
can use to set up to to set up alarms so
that um the retraining can be triggered
and i'm going to stop here um so that to
to have a to to take your questions
um we've been looking at quite a few
very quickly but we've been looking at
all of the steps in a typical machine
learning cycle
and tools even if they're not code but
most of them were code
and to make that collaboration with
humans a bit easier so that we can match
that knowledge about the business
with the knowledge about data that may
some a project a prototype go to the
product level
but the whole point of this is um it's
not really about the tools so um if you
remember this diagram about the swing
and the misunderstandings look at the
date
it's almost half a century old
so we were dealing with that half a
century ago
and we're still here now so these
challenges are going to stay there so
whenever you're seeing this
maybe there's no there's the tools i've
been talking to you about are not there
but make sure you look at how to improve
these three problems and make sure that
you you find the tools in your time that
help you
bring domain experts and data experts
together understand the problem
i'm going to stop now you can find me
well on gather town in a few minutes
or on linkedin or on twitter but i'm
happy to to take your questions now
thank you very much
thank you arena for the presentation uh
let's see if we have questions for you
all right we have a question for you
uh the question is although i understand
it is not really about the tools how
much effect does saving format of a
model have
well it does quite a bit because so um
if if for some reason you need to change
your libraries at the middle of the
project
if you had been storing it in a format
that had nothing to do with the target
platform then you need to go back to
square one
so for instance and and and that also
happens when you start collaborating
with other people and there's the um i'm
pi towards your tensorflow or now
there's pytorch mobile but not so long
ago patrick's mobile wasn't there so if
you were saving say um thinking that you
were going to be
um so you didn't think that you were
going to be deploying on an android
phone
and you were training on pytorch
and suddenly you need to use tensorflow
lite
you started having to you had problems
converting you had you had to look for
converters or write your own
and so anytime you you have to deal with
um with edge devices
or edge deployment
formatting
does matter yeah quite a bit
all right how does one introduce this in
the culture of a company and how easy is
it
so there's there's different things you
can do so it's it
it's easy or not depending on the on how
much sharing culture there can be
and you can introduce it simply by by
exposing people to these practices so
it's when when people say um
data science is a silo
it's not that by nature it has to be a
silo it's simply that people are used to
working that way so they were working
that way when they were in their studies
they were like that in grad school
so they continued because they thought
that's the way you work
if they are if they realize that there's
a another way of working
they see the benefits and they adopt it
so it doesn't have to be hard so ways of
doing that is through
these talks so meetups conferences um
hackathons uh getting out there
and and mixing with other people that
have other ways of working so i think
that's that's how you can introduce that
into into companies that's a nice way
i think they agree on this
uh so robert says great talk thank you
and
and tom has a remark for you uh
sometimes there's also purposeful of
execution on part of domain experts
and unwilling to relinquish their
position in the church
what do you want to say on this
uh
so i've i definitely haven't talked
about other human problems like
relationships and
and how you collaborate with others
because it really isn't about the
libraries it's about how you convince
someone who has a really different
mindset and your and maybe it's in a
really conservative industry
that what you're doing is actually going
to help them
that's a really long process of building
trust so
yeah that can happen but you need i
guess you need to play the the long-term
game and
and slowly build that trust with them
and convince them that it's really for
their benefit
um seems like uh
we don't have any more questions as of
now so arena uh i would like to thank
you very much for coming for the
presentation and it was a pleasure
having you thank you very much for
having me